pendant que la crise politique continue
de tout éclipsé que les élus touchés
tente d'éviter les questions
snc-lavalin subi un revers devant les
tribunaux en cour fédérale
la firme tentait une nouvelle fois
d'éviter un procès criminel pour fraude
et corruption en faveur d'une entente de
réparation mais la juge conclut que la
demande de contrôle judiciaire n'avait
aucune chance raisonnable de succès la
cour métier la décision du service des
poursuites pénales du canada qui avait
écarté l'option d'une entente avec snc
lavalin rappelons le pouvoir
discrétionnaire de la poursuite
l'entreprise est déçu un porte parole
écrit notre objectif était de négocier
un accord de réparation autant dans
l'intérêt du public dans l'intérêt de
nos parties prenantes innocente nos
employés clients investisseurs et
retraités
il n'y a plus que le nouveau procureur
général david lam eti qui pourrait
demander qu'un accord soit signé
c'est justement ce qui avait refusé de
faire l'ex ministre jody web de cet
automne son successeur
choisira-t-il d'intervenir il peut le
faire mais meilleure pression plus plus
grand sur ses épaules
la décision de la cour fédérale vient de
lui compliquer la tâche
contredire les tribunaux pourraient
envoyer un drôle de message et dans le
contexte de crise avec les démissions
les témoignages les allégations ça
devient difficile pour le ministre
d'agir c'est pas un climat favorable
bonne administration de la justice
échaudé le premier ministre n'ose pas
s'avancer
nous allons toujours cherché à
promouvoir plus devant emplois à travers
le pays avait pas à la décision sur une
entente de rémédiation ça c'est une
décision qui devra être prise et qui
doit y prise par le procureur général
pas le premier ministre si justin
trudeau vue protéger les emplois le chef
conservateur lui met en doute les
impacts éventuels d'un procès criminel
contre snc les menacer avec les procès
criminels
le nouveau procureur général david lam
et ea pourrait attendre contexte plus
favorable pour s'en mêler
possiblement après les prochaines
élections quant à snc lavalin elle a 30
jours pour porter
en appel la décision de la cour fédérale
ici louis blu-ray radio canada ottawa